buenas tardes aquí todo muy tranquilo
una jornada hasta ahora tranquila y eso
que se está viviendo también en medio de
fuertes medidas de seguridad ya que las
autoridades
bueno pues han advertido sobre posibles
protestas violentas a lo largo de este
día por ahora digo no estamos viendo
nada de eso eso sí en el capitolio de
este estado en sacramento si se supone
que hay preparada una protesta de
activistas a favor de trump en
aproximadamente unas dos horas pero la
policía las autoridades han variado toda
la zona por lo que es imposible acceder
dentro del capitolio precisamente para
evitar vivir escenas como las del 6 de
enero y aquí la comunidad tanto de
oakland como de san francisco bueno pues
aquí kamala harris tiene tiene muy buena
fama es una política muy querida en
general y es que kamala harris nació
aquí en oakland y se forjó forjó su
carrera política en la ciudad de san
francisco primero como fiscal del
distrito de esta ciudad después dio el
salto a la fiscalía general de
california y aunque este año
desgraciadamente por la pandemia no se
puede celebrar en las calles y las
autoridades también han pedido
la comunidad que por favor no salga a
las calles debido a esta crisis de salud
eso sí hay gente hay personas que han
decidido homenajear a su manera a harris
como por ejemplo varios dueños de
restaurantes que han preparado menús
especiales hoy para la inauguración de
bailén y de kamala también hay incluso
un heladero que ha creado un sabor de
helado especial al que ha llamado kamala
harris y que según él sabe a vainilla